spring and Jay Bilas from the mother
ship covering the draft last night with
the crew Jay good morning how you
feeling dan how you doing good to be
with you as always it's uh it's
spectacular to have you on and do you
want to weigh in on the poll question
who will be an all-star first Simmons or
Ingram my guess is it'll be Simmons but
it's kind of like asking you know
whether it's going to be lebron or
durant or something i'm not sure that
either these guys are quite that good
but Simmons is the best all-around
prospect I've seen since LeBron uh and
you know I I didn't think it was while
it was a reasonable question you should
certainly ask like you know which person
would you take I didn't think it was
that hard of a decision for Philadelphia
I thought they kind of had to go the
Simmons route because you just don't
find guys like that very often he's uh
he's physically imposing he's athletic
he's long he's and he's incredibly
skilled the only thing that Ingram does
better than Ben Simmons is shoot right
now and and I think you'll always shoot
better but I think Simmons is uh is will
be a much better shooter than then he
spot to be right now and you know Dan
you saw him play a lot in college I mean
you're harking back to a guy like Grant
Hill who they're not similar in body
style but they're similar in skill set
except Simmons a way better passer than
grant was at that time but you know
grant hill is first year took two
three-pointers made one and that was it
and if he had come out after his
freshman year like Simmons is doing the
knock-on to everybody say you can't
shoot and and so it's kind of a similar
you know you're projecting guy at that
age as to what he's going to be and I
think Simmons is going to get much
better as a shooter but the three was a
novelty back then now it's it's a given
that now we want to know if you can
shoot the three so can you teach Simmons
to be able to shoot the three yes uh you
can uh to wear it to where they have to
come out and guard am I'm not suggesting
he's gonna all of a sudden be one of the
splash brothers but he his mechanics are
not broken it is not something where
he's
incapable of doing it in fact his
coaching staff was really begging him to
shoot perimeter shots uh and it but he
gets to the basket so easily i mean i
thought it was remarkable you know did
some did some research talked a lot of
people just on some numbers issues that
would be a somewhat illuminating and uh
you know like they're all these lists of
NBA all-stars that he scored more points
than in college and you know like john
wall yeah he outscored john wallace in
college he outrebounded Kevin Love in
college he out assisted Steph Curry in
college Russell Westbrook in college
stuff like that and so for a guy that
some have said well you know he's not an
alpha dog I mean if he's not an alpha
dog why aren't the alpha dogs producing
more because I mean if he would it with
what is next after a beta dog or what is
like if he's a beta dog give me that guy
cuz he's he produces and and I think
he's going to produce at the NBA level
where the games a little more wide open
yeah but I I there's just something
missing there I don't know what happened
where his team doesn't make the NC
double-a tournament and maybe I'm being
I'm hung up on that Jay I just think if
you're if you're that good you it's it's
hard to not make the tournament now and
spare but but what I would say in
response to that these are not excuses
there but I guess you'd call them
reasons Keith Hornsby their best year
missed uh I think he missed like 15 or
16 games on the year half the season and
didn't play the second half of the year
or second half of conference plays out
and out for the season Craig Victor
transferred in didn't play the first 10
games and that was when they had their
their major problems and still LSU
played Kentucky in the last game for the
SEC regular season title and you know
they didn't go to the tournament not for
what they did in the SEC but for what
they didn't do in the non-conference and
so he had that I don't think it was a
anything to do with coaching or all that
stuff but what I would what I would ask
is if you swapped Simmons and Ingram and
Ingram went to LSU and Simmons went to
Duke what would we be saying about
Simmons we'd be we he'd have this glow
on him that that
that we wouldn't be able to shine off
and then we'd be gone I don't know about
about Ingram he's really skinny and
angie's you know he he doesn't he
doesn't have a you know doesn't throw
his brow when he plays and he's kind of
got a sleepy look to him you know stuff
like that I don't know that Brandon
Ingram as good as he is would have
gotten them for the tournament but I
think we would have seen a totally
different deal and that's why a lot of
people said you know if you've got a
brand like salmon you're a number one
player like Simmons you're being
followed around by a camera crew all
year like Simmons and you gotten his
shoe executives you're tripping over
them to get to get to the gym at LSU
would you be better off going to a
blueblood program where nobody's going
to question whether you're going to win
their day and you can you can produce
less and they're still going to
recognize your talent over everything
that's a hard question and I don't I
don't I don't know that Ben would do
anything any differently I'm telling
like that kid he's a good kid he's been
you know he's been the number one player
for so long you can't help but be a
little bit affected by that but you know
he came from from Australia and it kind
of reminds me a little bit of like what
people say about Sam Perkins that you
know he's so smooth and he doesn't he's
not overly emotional are demonstrative
and people somehow think he doesn't care
and I'm like no way I've seen him too
much to know the kid cares and he can he
can do this he can really play we're
talking to Jay Bilas to the mothership I
had a former ACC coach tell me yesterday
that I was off on ingraham because you
know everybody's caught up on his build
and he said let's look at all the
positives he does if the negative is
he's slight look at all the positives
that he does and he's a really good
player he can get to the hoop he can
shoot he's smart and so I I don't know
am I am I missing something on ingram is
is ingram is somebody who can contribute
next year for the Lakers yes yes is he
gonna lead like I don't know that any
any of these players now can come in at
age 20 or 19 whatever he's a vagrant a
full year younger than Ben Simmons so
he's got that sort of arc to have
improvement to go uh to get to the same
age I kill be better a year from
now but I don't think any of these guys
are going to make the kind of difference
that we would see years ago like when
Tim Duncan came into the league and all
of a sudden you went 30 more games or
some whatever it was I just don't see
that kind of thing happening it's just
it's two different now and the players
are younger and they need a little bit
more a little bit of time to adjust I
mean they're not Simmons is built like a
man yet but he's not he's not 21 he
can't even go into a bar and order a
drink so it's kind of a it's a different
time but Ingram is the Ingram's the real
deal to he's really good it's just it's
kind of the issue of if you had to think
if you had lebron and i keep going back
to Bondi these guys lebron but if you
had LeBron and Durant in the same year
you know you take LeBron first and you
wouldn't hesitate but it doesn't mean
that Durant's not really good like when
Durant came out I thought Odin I would
have taken Odin first and I think I
would have been in a long line of people
that are claiming you know that that
felt the same way and now are claiming
differently but but when Durant was
drafted I mean we were all saying this
guy is going to win a bunch of scoring
titles yeah you knew he is going to be
great it's just no you saw something
maybe a little bit better in another way
with a different player and that's kind
of the way I feel about the Simmons
ingram thing any new draft cliches the
draft in stash draft a'stache there's
three and d stretch for has become a big
deal now like everybody so stretch for
so so what what kind of crazy is we are
we are dealing with position lists and
stretch for like if its position lyst
why do we care with the guys stretch for
so we should really just go with he can
really shoot it I was amazed initially
when position list but but what position
to go to play please position was but he
doesn't have a position I was amazed the
number of times the references to
draymond Green a draymond Green type of
player or you know looking for a
draymond Green type of player it did you
guys kind of gather that that like
draymond Green can you get can you find
somebody that hybrid that he can play
different positions he's positioned
lists but it felt like draymond Green
was the object of desire in some of
these players in drafting them that made
they can be that kind of player we've
been through this but way more than I
have you notice pecially with the
mothership like you're asked the
question by maybe sports centers as
somewhere else it said all right who's
the next dream on green or who's the
dream on green in this class and you can
say look don't ask me that question
that's let's let's not do that or you
could just say you know what they're
gonna ask it anyway so I might as well
just answer and that's kind of that's
kind of the way the way it goes
sometimes it's like back when back when
we started doing on on basketball game
day we started doing pics like football
does and i railed against what I'm like
me you know we don't know who's going to
win and then I decided you know what I'm
going to lose this I might as well just
make the pick it and and just hope they
don't ask me to put a mascot head on
before I let you go we had Patrick Ewing
on last hour and I brought up some
quotes that John Thompson made about
Patrick and and big men and how they're
perceived as head coaching candidates is
there a perception of profile a bias
against taller coaches as patrick said
you know we always look at the point
guard that he sees the floor or if
you're a big guy you're on the floor
just because you're a big guy where is
the little guy has to be able to prove
that he can play is there a bias that
goes on i don't know if i call it bias
but i do think there's something built
in where you know it's always the point
guard that the is the extension of the
coach on the floor and that the floor
leader and all that stuff and you know
I've known Patrick since i played
against them when i was in high school
and an all-star game he's from the east
coast I'm I grew up out west and got to
know him when when we were both in
college and and what one what a great
dude but he I can't believe that he's
not getting more more attention as as a
coaching candidate and he should be up
there but look at all the guys that
there are all these guys are guards and
uh and like I can't think of many big
guys that are coaches right now Larry
Cristo be AXA the coach a Utah but
outside of that mallu point it seems
like if you're tall enough to ride the
rides you are disqualified from coaching
how did you do against Ewing in an
all-star game I scored 14 points and and
I was very proud of myself he probably
had like 20 80
but uh one of my teammates broke the
back board before the game we played a
Pepperdine and uh so you know I die by
that's what that's what I do like I tell
everybody yeah you know I played against
Michael Jordan college yeah Ewing and I
swear to god he didn't even know who I
was I don't think he I don't think he
knew I was even out there but I can
claim that i played against them does
Jordan know you were on the floor yeah
cuz I keep saying that I was but I think
he'd rather have the the half a billion
dollars in the fact that that we beat
them the last time the two teams play oh
yeah I got that going for me which is
nice AJ it was great stuff last night
tell the crew Congrats was a fun watch
thanks for joining with a pleasure of my
brother thank you right at shea bill is
to the mothership the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience